m
c'est au village corail à saint-gilles
que s'est déroulé pour la première fois
cette année la journée partenariale de
l'action sociale une journée organisée
par les travailleurs sociaux et les
partenaires du travail social afin de
réunir le monde de l'intervention
sociale médico-sociale socio éducatives
et de l'insertion autour d'engagements
les plus innovants aujourd'hui cette
journée organisée dans l'ouest permet
aux professionnels aux bénévoles aux
familles et aux élus de terrain que nous
sommes de ceux rencontrés dans des
ateliers où chacun aura la possibilité
d'exprimer ses idées ses projets et
parfois aussi d'obtenir des réponses à
des questions qu'on se pose sur les
différentes problématiques sociales que
ce soit pour les jeunes des personnes
âgées les personnes handicapées les
familles en difficulté donc il y à ici
une mutualisation de ses personnels
une mise en commun des compétences et
des expériences
l'idée c'est de continuer à réfléchir
sur pourquoi le travail social à quoi ça
sert
et comment est ce qu'on peut améliorer
l'accompagnement de nos publics les plus
précaires vert de l'autonomie vers le
développement individuel le
développement des territoires
ça c'est l'objectif final tout au long
de la journée ont été proposés des
ateliers et débats ou encore des exposés
qui ont permis le partage d'expériences
afin de faire naître une culture commune
cette journée a permis aux
professionnels d'échanger de mieux se
connaître mais surtout de rendre
l'action auprès de la population plus
efficace tant humainement que
socialement
aujourd'hui c'est l'occasion de mettre
aussi l'en-avant ce qu'on fait au niveau
du département et de mettre en avant
aussi le travail qui fait que les
partenaires
voilà tout ça dans l'intérêt bien sûr de
la population pour laquelle auprès de
laquelle nous intervenons nous avons mis
en place des ateliers justement pour
permettre à chacun de se retrouver
d'avoir des conseils de trouver les
paies des professionnels qui pour les
aider en cas de problème et ça permet
aussi à nous professionnels
médico-sociaux de travailler ensemble
sur sur cette prise en charge qui est
très complexe mais qui a besoin de tous
les acteurs du terrain alors donc pour
nous les pôle insertion
donc il faut savoir qu'on est capable
insertion sur le bassin ouest les sites
une première participation
donc il est important pour nous à
travers de cette journée de partenariat
d'action sociale de présenter à nos
collègues des autres services
départements à nos partenaires
institutionnels et aux acteurs non
mission et nos interventions dans
l'accompagnement des bénéficiaires de
rsa
donc il faut rappeler question le bassin
ouest y en a trois mille personnes dont
et perfore cette prestation
cette journée dans l'ouest a été une
réussite
trois prochaines journées partenariales
de l'action sociale se dérouleront tout
au long du mois de septembre dans les
arrondissements est sud et nord